okay um
so good so far
he disconnected needed a little break
apparently
it's not playing poorly at all it's just
that
so far i don't think i'm making any
major blunders and if i don't make any
major bonders
then i should in general be able to to
play better than he does
and also i'm aided by the fact that
there's increment here so i can
i can sort of yap on as much as i want
and i'm still gonna be fine in terms of
in terms of time okay so let's change it
up
see what he does against e4
she goes for e5
okay let's see oh we're gonna have a
theme tournament huh
there's a berlin okay
so let's just do what carl's been doing
against me
it's worked for him so why can't it work
for me right
uh okay
ah there are lots of ways to play here
but
yeah i don't know i don't really know
the difference
in um there are there's there are
certainly subtle differences but i don't
really know them so that's
why i
i'm just gonna just gonna play in a more
or less straightforward way
um should i go a4
just to stop the expansion probably i
should
let's go mission g5 broke f6 and then
you claim that you have a target there
yep then i don't think i'm majorly
worried about day three so
i'm just gonna go
push them pawns
knight b6
okay that is clever it's exploiting the
fact that
cannot go knight e3 because i dropped
the bottom h on
sorry on g4 and you can support that
[ __ ] with h5
later on so yeah this is apparently
why i don't why you don't play exactly
this way
okay we'll take it that's that's all
right rook g1
i think black is more than fine here
bishop pair and
and a very sound position but
i'm not i'm not that worried i think i
should go a3
because i don't want to allow b4 and
then b3
and obviously if you had played a3
himself i would have closed up with
with b3
now i push
c5
okay i think we'll
try and redirect the knights
you can go h6 at any point yeah that's
what he does as well
quite sensibly and then i don't really
have an attack
um
now yeah now i don't really see what i
can do
i can go f4 but i don't believe in it it
takes i'm gonna go c4 i think i should
uh i think i just i should just keep the
position more or less closed and
admit that i really haven't achieved a
lot here
and just just try and hold for the
moment
and see if i can get any chances to play
actively later on
maybe knight h4 was stupid actually
i was kind of hoping he didn't
he wouldn't realize that he should go
you should go h6 there
which is a bit neat say the least
i should take this
doesn't look very appealing but now i'm
maybe getting bishop b4
possibly root d1 first
and once that yeah i think c4 was uh was
a mistake by him because now i can
exchange the bishops later on
i can sort of try and try and equalize
here
um and you know maybe even hope for more
at some point
probably should have gone for b4 instead
and just
pushed on there because this is a little
bit too soft i think
the average v6 is very sensible
oh wait a sec
i go for two rooks versus the queen
bishop a5 takes on d1 takes everything
queen b6
i think the answer in a blitz game is
most
assuredly yes i think this is also like
objectively pretty reasonable too
he doesn't have a choice so it's quite
important that i have queen b6
i believe
bishop c4 there's 93
no there's not but there's bishop b4
knight e3 there's rook d6 i think
well there's queen seven still no
worries
no worries if he takes an f5 i'll
take back with the cheap one probably
and i'm very happy here
um his pieces are at least for the
moment fairly
passive there's no rook um
there's no rook c8 because there was um
nastiness happening there um
wait a sec maybe i should go bishop c3
although there is rook d7 okay i think
i would just grab for now rookie 4
obviously isn't possible because of uh
queen d phone jack
yeah this is becoming very unpleasant
friend
okay there's bishop c3 rook e4 there's
queen b7 attacking both rooks check on
g4 that's king h3
still attacking both rooks and this
means that i'm winning the pawn
on b7 he's still pretty far from
winning the game though he'll um
he'll coordinate his rooks and uh
and try and put up a defense this is not
the way though
because now he's losing another pawn on
on a
on a4 and i don't think he has any kind
of play like
there is just no there's just no
scenario here i think where i'm ever
getting majorly troubled
in terms of king safety um
yeah let me go
yeah probably just queen c4
bishop d4 bishop d2 i guess
i gotta be a bit faster five
maybe this wasn't ideal but i think it's
it's quite
quite good enough c3 you can take
f2 i don't think there's a perpetual
king of three there are no checks
maybe i spoke too soon
maybe i spoke way too soon
i'm getting nervous here
i can't stop rook g2 right rt2r2
[Music]
that was stupid ah really really stupid
c3 there i mean i saw bishop b2 existed
but i just couldn't believe it
bishop too okay uh very
very nice trick that he found there but
uh and as i said he he does fight very
well
but i there is no way